[Music]
william shakespeare
considered to be one of the greatest
playwrights ever born he wrote plays
like romeo and juliet
hamlet and a midsummer night's dream but
there's another one of his works that
may have been lost to history
it's called cardinio you won't find it
in a book or on stage
but perhaps in an adaptation of it from
1727
a play going by the name double
falsehood which claims to have preserved
the bard's original script
but is this an elaborate hoax or a
genuine shakespearean play
to be or not to be that is the question
act 1 the curtain closes
we open this story with a death on the
23rd of april 1616
following an illustrious career of
playwriting and poetry
william shakespeare dies aged 52.
now it's not certain how he passed but
the local vicar wrote later
that shakespeare and his friends quote
had a merry meeting
and it seems drank too hard for
shakespeare died of a fever
there contracted during his lifetime
shakespeare did not publish any of his
plays himself
it seems like he expected his
extraordinary works to die with him
or simply fade away from history the
only written record of shakespeare's
plays during his lifetime were through
little pamphlets
called quartos these quarters were small
flimsy pieces of paper
folded twice over to make four leaves
each quarto contained a single play
and while some were quite accurate in
other cases some had rather dubious
contents
these quote unquote bad quartos were
often just written from vague memory
they didn't preserve the play word for
word and the verses were jumbled
lines were missing and other parts of
the play were simply paraphrased
in other words there were cheap
shakespeare knockoffs sold for about a
sixpence
that's about five pounds or six dollars
in today's money
in light of these quote stolen and
superititious copies
a group of shakespeare's friends and
colleagues notably two actors from
shakespeare's dramatic company john
hemmings and henry condell
collected his works into one official
document
being actors for shakespeare himself
they were able to faithfully memorize
much of the plays themselves
but to fill in any gaps they used
whatever they could find any of the good
quartos
prompt books lying about and in some
cases shakespeare's private working
drafts
all of these original documents being
paper are now likely lost to history
but finally some seven years later in
1623
john hemmings and henry condell
published the first
folio a definitive collection of
shakespeare's works
you can think of it as an early
shakespeare canon it contained 36 plays
18 of which had never been officially
published plays like 12th night
macbeth julius caesar and the tempest
had their first folio not been published
these plays might never have survived
needless to say
the first folio is one of the most
important books ever written in the
english language
it contains some of the finest poems and
plays ever written
nowadays if you were to pick up a copy
of the complete works of shakespeare
what you're reading is taken from the
first folio however
the first folio didn't preserve all of
shakespeare's works
the collection is known to emit two of
his plays pericles and edward iii
whether these plays were actually
authored by shakespeare is still heavily
debated
and outside the scope of this video but
both are believed to be partially
written by shakespeare
in fact it was quite common for
playwrights to collaborate in the last
phase of his career
shakespeare collaborated with john
fletcher to produce plays like henry
viii
and two noble kingsmen think of it as a
sort of shakespeare collab
anyway both these texts pericles and
edward iii are now included into the
shakespeare canon
and thus complete the collection well
also you'd think act
2 the lost history of cardinio
in 1653 nearly four decades after
shakespeare's death
a record book called the stationers
register made an entry that shakespeare
put on a play in 1613 going by the name
of the history of cardinio
another clue is the name cardinio
cardinio is a character in the spanish
novel don quixote written by miguel de
cervantes
with an english translation published in
1612 the year before
the history of cardinio was allegedly
performed
if you're unfamiliar with don quixote is
a great story it's all about a man
called alonso who believes that he is a
knight
and he takes the name don quixote and
decides to go on many trafalg
misadventures
meeting many curious characters along
the way one of which
is a man called cardinio in this
particular episode
don and his partner sancho meet this
strange hermit in the mountains
who tells them both a sad story of a
failed love
many years ago cardenia was due to marry
his lover
lucinda for help with this cardino asked
his friend
don ferdinando to arrange a wedding but
when don
ferdinando laid eyes upon lucinda he
decided to steal her from cardinio
at the same time don ferdinando was
already betrothed to a young woman
called dorothea
don ferdinando hatches a plan he sends
cardinio on an errand
and with him out the picture he asks
lucinda's father
for her hand in marriage surprisingly
the father agrees
and the wedding between the two is
underway cardinal returns from his
errand
and stumbles across the wedding hiding
behind a tapestry he watches the event
as it unfolds
at the climactic moment when the vows
are exchanged lucinda
dismayed agrees to marry don ferdinando
and the knot is tied between her
and her treacherous new husband
devastated
cardinio runs away to live in the
mountains yet some time later
lucinda runs away from don ferdinando
and realizing the error of his ways
don fernando finds cardinio and finally
apologizes
cardinio forgives him and then is
reunited with lucinda
finally don ferdinando makes things up
with dorothea
it's this story that could have been the
plot of shakespeare's play that
supposedly happened in 1613.
the date seemed to add up we know that
translation of don quixote was published
in england
in 1612 the year before and so
shakespeare may have had access to the
source material
from which to base his play around as
for an actual play or script
well we don't have it since a copy of it
is not in the first folio
the contents of the play is lost it
would be a miracle
should one of these original quarto
manuscripts ever be found
act three double falsehood
well such a miracle may have happened
our story takes us to the 13th of
december
1727 111 years after shakespeare's death
it was the opening night of a much
discussed play in london
the player's name was double falsehood
and was presented to the public
by louis theobold the title page or the
published version reads as following
written originally by w shakespeare and
now revised and adapted
to stage by mr theobold looking at the
language of the play
and it seems quite shakespearean for an
18th century theatergoer this all would
have been very antiquated and so the
claims made by double falsehood
may indeed seem authentic but the most
intriguing part of the play
is its plot in five acts double
falsehood tells us the story of cardinio
from don quixote
except that now the character's names
have changed
cardinio becomes julio lucinda becomes a
leonora don ferdinando is turned into
henriquez
and dorothea into violente and aside for
some added violence and grit
double falsehood is remarkably similar
to the story of cardinio
so how can we make sense of these two
pieces of evidence
we have this play double falsehood that
tells the story of cardinio
an independent of this we have evidence
that there was indeed a play performed
in 1613
called the history of cardinio this
can't be a coincidence
there must be something more well the
place publisher
louis theobald claimed to have come into
three manuscripts of an unnamed play of
shakespeare that he collected together
and edited into a single work which he
titled double falsehood
he was secretive on where he got those
manuscripts leaving many to believe that
he forged them himself
theobold was a lawyer by trade but in
recent years had become a writer
fascinated with shakespeare and very
familiar with his work
it is entirely possible he had a decent
level of knowledge in which to produce a
plausible forgery of shakespeare
many see double falsehood as an
imitation of shakespeare's work
and a good one at that it uses his
vocabulary and style
either way such claims dogged theobald's
career and the play never took off
he sold the rights away and faded away
from the spotlight
and in the following centuries nobody
really gave any attention to double
falsehood
simply assuming that indeed it probably
was a forgery
but in recent years scholars have
challenged the view that double
falsehood is an out and out forgery
on a closer look at the script it seems
that three distinct writing styles
make up the play three sets of
vocabulary and three
sets of influences these three voices of
double falsehood
the first voice appears most prominently
in acts 1
2 and the first part of act 3. the style
and language
are very close to shakespeare's later
plays the second voice
comes in at acts 4 and 5 except that is
it uses a more modern turn of phrase
instead of hath and doth it prefers has
and does
much like how we'd say it nowadays and
finally the third voice crops up
throughout the play
sometimes in individual sentences and
other times in full paragraphs
it bridges the gaps for the other two
voices a lot of the vocabulary and
phrasing it uses
doesn't really seem very shakespearean
it even references political events
dating it to sometime in the early 1700s
this has challenged the idea that double
falsehood is a simple forgery
if theobald was able to construct three
textual voices in his play
each with a distinct vocabulary in
phraseology then he would have been a
mastermind counterfeiter
which to me and many others seems quite
unlikely
scholars argue that voice three the one
that pissed throughout the play
and bridges the gaps between other
writers is most likely theobolds himself
we know that theobold edited the play
out of an existing manuscript so his
traces in the play
seem to be stitching the whole thing
together that leaves us with voices one
and two
the original voices who wrote the play
voice one
is acts 1 2 and 3 and voice 2 is acts 4
and 5.
so it's believed that acts 1 2 and 3
preserved a text believed to be
shakespeare himself
it's the more antiquated of the two and
many language studies
have linked the vocabulary to a lot of
shakespeare's plays especially those
later ones
and the rest of the play likewise acts 4
and 5 do appear to have
language and phrasing most similar to
john fletcher
so putting it all together acts 1 2 and
3 are shakespeare
acts 4 and 5 john fletcher and the whole
thing is tied together and stitched up
by louis theobald the editor double
holstered preserves the remains of the
original play cardinio as alluded to
in the stationers register in 1653 louis
theobald's bold claim that shakespeare
wrote his play
largely holds up but instead of
shakespeare writing the whole play
it's more that traces and remnants of
shakespeare can be found
within the play especially in the early
half
the only thing we can't be certain of is
how theobold actually got hold of those
three manuscripts
with the text of cardinio he was very
secretive about this precious piece of
evidence
and since we no longer have it today we
must assume that the original cardinio
manuscripts were destroyed
so what's left in double falsehood is
probably our best look at this lost play
of shakespeare
well they have it cardinio the lost
player of shakespeare
i really hope you enjoyed this video i
want to keep experimenting with all the
videos i make
and keep exploring obscure topics that
deserve more attention
so if you'd like to see more why not
subscribe a like and a comment really
help out too
and if you haven't already i'm on
instagram and twitter now i'm aiming to
put some behind scenes content out on
there
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time goodbye